growing concerns over the terror threat
at our border in the wake of the attacks
in Israel border patrol sources
confirming to Fox that two men in their
20s from Lebanon were apprehended at
Eagle in Eagle Pass Texas they are
considered to be special interest aliens
and are currently undergoing extensive
background vetting the former acting
director Vice giving this
warning I've never been more concerned
about the Safety and Security this
nation I am right now I'm telling you
something's coming I I don't know how
many terrorists have cross border but
someday we're going to find out it's
going to be a bad day for America around
the table we don't have a lot of time
Pete is that concern of his warranted of
course we are so stupid and so
vulnerable right now we have no policy
we have no idea we have no idea what
those intentions are and someday it's
going to come back to bite us Martha
would you shut down the Border I agree
with you Peter would you shut down the
border is this a is a is this a how
doing on the 20 mi of wall that was
going to be built and when can we expect
that to be finished and if we while
we're waiting for it we need to close
that whole area off if it's a big enough
concern to start building that 20 mi
then we need to shut it down and deal
with the people that we have here 151
people on the terror watch list Fran
Townsen this morning from the U Bush uh
Administration she said she's terrified
she's a pretty steady Edie she said I'm
terrified about it she really is um Jess
said what your thoughts about this I
think there's going to be another 911
and it's going to come in through the
South and Joe Biden's going to have
blood on his hands and we've been
warning him for years about this and he
has no plan 99% of the people that cross
over he doesn't even Deport he just lets
stay here and then you pick him up on
some stupid felony charge and the guy
has a thing court appearance in
2028 never going to show
anyway you know what has happened to
this country uh especially during the
Biden Administration the numbers that
are coming through Now is really a crime
against the country and against the
Citizens and it's going to it's going to
backfire and it's going to backfire soon
I I tend to agree with this C I think we
got to shut the border down and get get
control of wh who's here who's on that
they're already here well we should find
them we we know they're here so we
should find them till we do it hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now